russian state television is broadcasting
pictures that it says shows dozens of
ukrainian soldiers surrendering in the
besieged southern port city of mariupol
russia says more than one thousand
soldiers have laid down their arms
but ukraine disputes that and insists
resistance by its forces is continuing
the city's mayor has accused russian
forces of committing war crimes and
disposing of victims bodies while
keeping the city sealed off
sadly there are still over 100 000
people in mariopol waiting for
evacuation there are also people in the
outskirts who are packed and ready to
leave that's another sixty thousand
people making conditions worse no
humanitarian corridors were able to open
on wednesday for people to escape the
fighting and move to the relative safety
of the west of the country the
ukrainians accuse russian forces of
violating agreements that would keep the
corridors safe a claim russia denies
meanwhile ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has accused the russians of
using phosphorus bombs
against residential areas and civilian
infrastructure the russian army uses all
types of artillery all types of missiles
including phosphorus bombs and other
ammunition banned under international
law
zielenski also said tens of thousands of
civilians have so far been killed by
invading russian forces
russia has categorically denied
committing any war crimes rob mcbride al
jazeera leviev